NARRATOR: This is a photo of
the North Korean military.
It looks surprisingly
candid, given how secretive
the North Korean
government is known
to be about affairs of state.
Then unsurprisingly, it is also
a photo that was planned out.
Not so much by the photographer,
but by North Korea itself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT PAISH: Hi, my
name is Matt Paish.
I'm a video producer
based in Bath, in the UK.
The photo was taken on the
9th of September, 2012,
which is actually National
Day in North Korea.
So what we can see in
photo are some soldiers
from the Korean People's Army.
Most of them are
facing away, towards
a huge, huge, huge,
monument, which
comprises two very big statues
of the leaders of North Korea.
NARRATOR: Matt was visiting
North Korea while on vacation,
which might come as a surprise.
The hermit kingdom is not
known for it's booming tourism
industry.
But still, Matt found
himself here, on a bus,
trying to figure out
this strange country.
MATT PAISH: The tour I
took lasted for eight days,
and what's most of the sites
we visited were in Pyongyang.
Activities on the
itinerary included
visiting many, many
statues and monuments.
We went to a couple of farms,
we went to a fruit processing
farm, an ostrich farm, we went
to an acrobatic show, a circus,
we visited a maternity hospital,
a university, a music Academy,
a museum of gifts
to the Great Leader.
You did get the impression
that they've just
been created purely for
tourists, to go to on a bus.
There were no other
people around there.
NARRATOR: But this
insanely regimented tour
may not have been the most off
putting thing Matt experienced.
MATT PAISH: One of the
things that people ask you
when you go on holiday,
is usually, you know,
how were the people.
Well, in North Korea,
we didn't really
meet any of the people
so-- Other countries
that you go to, that
you may stand out,
and you're clearly a
foreigner, people are generally
quite interested in you
and you can see people just
staring at you perhaps.
But in fact, that
didn't happen at all
in Pyongyang, which is
really quite a bizarre thing.
People were walking past
you, but they're not
looking at you at all.
So it's really strange thing.
NARRATOR: So this
picture of the soldiers
was kind of emblematic
of the trip in general.
A carefully managed
view of North Koreans,
with no actual
interaction or information
about them or their lives.
It was a trip full
of moments like this.
Matt, and North Koreans, at a
distance, hardly able to even
acknowledge each
other's existence.
MATT PAISH: North Korea
is one of these places
that you hear an awful lot about
in the news and in the media.
So being able to
actually go to the place,
and see real people walking
around in Pyongyang,
was a real insight.
And I consider
myself to be quite
privileged to have seen it.
NARRATOR: At This
Happened Here, we're
always coming up
with creative ways
to tell stories through photos.
Domain.com is the place to go
when that next great idea hits
you.
It's a one stop shop for all
of your domain and web hosting
needs.
Because you watch
This Happened Here,
you can get 20% off new
domain's, web hosting,
and email, by using the code
"happened" when you check out.
For more This Happened
Here, check out
this episode on how
photographers can
change your perceptions of war.
A US Marine experiences
an extremely close call
from a Taliban attack.
The dirt wall protecting him,
exploding from an enemy bullet.
We can see that the
soldier is in danger,
but what about the person
who took the photo?
And as always, don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.